Speaker 1: A ten year old girl is now being
denied an abortion in Ohio and is going to
have to travel across state lines in order
to get an abortion because of a pregnancy
that resulted from a rape.
Now, a few people e-mailed me last week saying,
you know, David, you played this clip of the
speaker of the House of Mississippi saying
I would be against an abortion, even for a
12 year old made pregnant by her own father.
And some of you wrote to me and said that
was such a meaningless clip, David, because
it's a hypothetical.
That's just that guy's opinion.
There is no such situation.
And his opinion isn't the law in Mississippi
anyway, so it doesn't matter.
Well, these are relevant hypotheticals because
they do happen.
And here is a non hypothetical.
A non.
This is a real story.
The Hill reports ten year old girl denied
abortion in Ohio.
A ten year old girl was denied an abortion
in Ohio after the Supreme Court ruled last
week that it was overturning Roe v Wade, demonstrating
the tangible impacts that the high court's
decision is having on patients seeking access
to the medical procedure.
A child.
This is a horrible, horrible story.
A child abuse doctor in Ohio contacted Dr.
Caitlin Bernhardt Barnard, an obstetrician
gynecologist in Indiana, after receiving a
ten year old patient.
Six weeks and three days pregnant.
The patient is now heading west to Indiana.
Given that an abortion ban in Ohio, which
prohibits the medical procedure when fetal
cardiac activity begins around six weeks,
had become effective quickly after the high
court issued its decision.
Several groups filed a lawsuit seeking to
block the state law from taking effect.
On Wednesday, an emergency stay of the abortion
ban was rejected by the Ohio Supreme Court
Friday, meaning the ban can be upheld as the
case is reviewed.
Ohio is among a number of states that have
rolled back abortion access since the Supreme
Court eliminated the constitutional right
to an abortion.
Some laws have been paused pending legal challenges,
but Indiana could soon find itself passing
its own abortion law later this month, given
that a special session has been scheduled
for later in July.
So understand what is going on here.
We have had all sorts of different laws around
the country over the last 50 years, quite
frankly, the Roe v Wade era and in fact, longer.
There are leftover laws from before the Roe
v Wade era that were effectively.
What's the castrated?
I don't know, the right where they were.
They were sort of like kneecapped, for lack
of a better term, because of Roe v Wade.
So there are preexisting laws that just weren't
really enforced because of Roe v Wade.
You then had other laws passed during the
Roe v Wade era, some of which were sort of
like inactive because of Roe v Wade, others
which were actually struck down.
And then you had some states that have what
are called trigger laws, where they say if
Roe v Wade is suspended or overturned, then
this law goes into effect.
And some of them happened immediately.
And in some places they were being temporarily
stopped during the review of the law and in
some places they are in place.
So here is a non hypothetical and the reaction
from some is, well, we should be more concerned
with how the ten year old got pregnant in
the first place, not about giving people abortion
on demand.
Well, but hold on a second.
She is pregnant right now.
And in fact, any delay for her reduces the
number of places where she can legally get
an abortion.
Right.
If you can get if if the idea is, well, it's
too late in Ohio, but you can go to Indiana.
I don't know the law in Indiana.
Off the top of my head.
But imagine that in Indiana, you can go until
nine weeks.
Well, if you can delay her two and a half
weeks now, she can't get the abortion in Indiana
while we figure out how did she get pregnant
in the first place.
You need to be concerned both about how this
happened and how to deal with the aftermath.
And forcing a pregnancy on a ten year old
is not going to help her trauma.
Now, is this what what Republicans want?
Is this the country that Republicans want
will know they would say we would prevent
the rape pregnancy to begin with.
That was one from Texas in Texas when Texas
passed its law at this point.
Was it a few months ago?
Maybe a year ago?
I'm not sure.
And Greg Abbott was asked, well, what about,
you know, victims of rape who end up pregnant
or children, victims of rape?
And he said, well, we're this is Texas.
We're going to prevent rape.
Right.
Well, even a very well-functioning criminal
justice system is not particularly good at
preventing crime, criminal justice systems.
Okay.
You look at large scale frauds of different
kinds and extortions.
Sometimes you can prevent crime.
But when it comes to street crime and when
it comes to rape and when it comes to murder,
in a lot of these different things, law enforcement
is not particularly good at preventing crime.
We can we can look at policy that would reduce
the amount of that crime.
But the idea that Texas police are going to
prevent these scenarios from ever happening,
it's absurd.
And of course, it doesn't work and doesn't
happen.
So I would say to them, well, how are you
going to do that?
Here we have a situation.
This is exactly what we've been talking about.
Last week it was a hypothetical about a 12
year old placed to the Mississippi speaker
of the House.
Oh, but, David, that's a that's a hypothetical.
Well, here we've got a real one.
And now this ten year old has to leave Ohio.
Is it better for.
I mean, listen, ultimately, she's going to
get the abortion.
It may already have happened.
It's been a few days, you know, over the holiday
weekend.
Is it better for her to have to go to Indiana
and leave Ohio because of the law?
Doesn't seem like it.
And by the way, there are Republicans asked
about this who aren't even saying, no, no,
no, no, it would be totally different in our
state.
Let's talk about
that next.